إذا كانت الموجة الأولى في إسرائيل من kovat 19
قصة نجاح ، فإن الموجة الثانية تظهر
بوتيرة سريعة لنهاية مختلفة تمامًا ،
فأنا أعتني بنفسي وأغسل
يدي ولا أقترب من الناس
كثيرًا ، وآمل أن يكون الأمر على ما يرام قريبًا مع
فيروس كورونا.  ارتفاع عدد الحالات في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، وأوقفت الحكومة
إغلاق القاعات العامة ، والحانات ، وصالات الألعاب الرياضية
، وأكثر من ذلك ، حيث بلغ معدل البطالة بالفعل أكثر
من 20 في المائة ، ويحاول رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو تجنب
إغلاق كامل آخر اليوم ، وهناك حوالي
90 حالة خطيرة
ويتضاعف العدد كل أربعة  أيام إذا لم
نتحرك الآن ، فستكون هناك مئات
الآلاف من الحالات الشديدة في الأسابيع المقبلة
والتي ستشل أنظمتنا
عندما أعيد فتح البلاد في أوائل مايو ،
بدت إسرائيل وكأنها
قصة نجاح دولية لفيروس كورونا.
نتنياهو كان يركب
تلك الموجة الأولى في معدلات التأييد العالية
ثم جاءت الموجة الثانية من
الإصابات اليومية التي زادت  ased 50 ضعف 20
حالة جديدة في اليوم هي الآن ألف حالة إصابة جديدة
نشطة عند مستويات قياسية
وانخفضت نسبة موافقة نتنياهو على التعامل مع كوفات 19 بنسبة 74
في المائة في مايو إلى 46 في المائة الآن
وفقًا للاستطلاع الأخير الذي أجرته حكومة الوحدة الوطنية التي
تشكلت خصيصًا لـ
التعامل مع فيروس كورونا يبدو أكثر
قلقًا من الخلافات السياسية ، ويخشى 60 في
المائة من الإسرائيليين على
مستقبلهم المالي ، والقلق هو أن الوضع السيئ
لا يزال أسوأ في أواخر أبريل ،
قال نتنياهو إن إسرائيل
نجحت في مهمتها لمكافحة
فيروسات كورونا حيث بدأ في تخفيف
القيود وفتح  الاقتصاد
لكن المهمة لم تنته بعد أورن
ليبرمان سي إن إن القدس